in the last video I challenged you to
write multiple Fibonacci functions ones
that could calculate the nth term of the
Fibonacci sequence either iteratively or
recursively and I'll take the first shot
right over here and I'll show you over
the next few videos that there's really
multiple ways of even doing this just
iteratively so let's define our function
Fibonacci fibonacci and it has a
parameter n so that's what we're going
to that is what we are going to pass
pass to the function and we know that by
definition the first two terms of the
Fibonacci sequence are 0 and 1 so let's
do let's make a list for ourselves and
so and so this is interesting so there's
the first time we're really going to do
some you know actual list manipulation
in this video so the terms here the
zeroth term of the Fibonacci sequence is
0 and the first one is 1 this is by
definition so we're just gonna we're
just gonna kind of hard code that in
right there and then what we're gonna do
is is if we're then going to construct
this list to all of the terms up to and
including the nth term and then return
the nth term from that list and the
reason why I'm going to do it this way
is it's able to save up kind of a memory
of all of the Fibonacci numbers which is
helpful for computing each incremental
Fibonacci number so let's do it this way
I'm gonna use a while loop you could do
it using a for loop but for me a while
loop feels a little bit more natural for
this and actually before I even define
the while loop I'm gonna set my my
variable of either 8th iteration I
should say I'm going to set that equal
to 0 and you're gonna see how this works
in a second so I'm gonna say while while
I is less than or equal to n so i's
gonna start at 0 and then go up to n and
actually you know frankly i shouldn't
start at 0 because we already have the
0th term here in the first term here and
we want to construct the 2nd 3rd 4th all
the way to the nth term so actually
let's start i at 2 so we already have
the 0 term in the first term we then
want to construct the second term so
that's where we're gonna start I equate
up to and including the nth term so
that's why we say less than or equal to
n we're gonna keep adding terms to this
sequence
so while I is less than or equal to n
I'm going to take I'm gonna take this
list right here and to the end of that
list and this is a built-in function for
any list in Python and you're learning
it now and you could look it up and
actually my IDE tells me how to use it I
can add to the end of that list another
term and that next term I'm going to add
to the end of the list is going to be
the sum of the previous two terms so
it's going to be term it's going to be
terms I minus one so that's the previous
term terms I minus one literally refers
to the previous term I minus one plus
terms plus terms I minus two so this is
essentially going to construct this
Fibonacci Fibonacci sequence and build
it in this list and then we're going to
increment I I is equal to I plus one if
we never increment if we never increment
I then this loop will just keep going on
forever and ever but this way it's going
to keep going up and up and up until at
some point I is not going to be less
than or equal to n and then we're going
to break out of the loop and then when
we break out of the loop when we break
out of the loop let me do it right over
it when we break out of out of the loop
we can then return the nth Fibonacci
term in the sequence so we're gonna
return terms terms we're going to return
the nth term in terms so let's see if
this works let's see it does this make
sense so I'm gonna go all the way up to
the nth term all the way up to the nth
term and actually the nth term here yes
this should work because if I had if
this was Fibonacci of 0 I wanted to
return
terms of 0 which is this term right here
if it's term if it's Fibonacci of 1 I
want to return this term right over here
so it's the first term in terms right
you're not the 0th but the first so this
this feels like it should work in
actually even before I run it I want you
to make sure you understand what I've
done here with the list so I'm going to
show you a little bit of an example of
how these lists work so if I define a
list as I don't know 1 1 comma 2
that's my list and if I then say it's
doing something weird so I'm gonna
define my list as one comma two so
define it so if I type a it's 1 comma 2
if I append to a a dot append so I'm if
I append a let's say I append a 7 to it
then if I look at a I've have a 7 at the
end of it if I want to refer to the
elements here a of 0 should be the first
element a the second element I put just
put the 2 in the brackets it should give
me the 7 so that's exactly what I'm
doing over here I'm saying terms of I
minus 1 so we're we're going to add a
new term over here so this first time we
go through the loop we're gonna add a
new term and it's going to be the sum of
but it's going to be the sum of terms of
I minus 1 so in that first in that first
loop I is 2 I minus 1 is 1 so terms of 1
plus terms of 0 so it's going to be
terms of 1 which is 1 plus terms of 0
and then it keeps doing that all the way
until we construct the nth term well
enough talk and I'll step through it a
little bit clearer in the next video
with a particular example but let's just
see if what we wrote actually works so
let me let me run it alright and let's
see if we get the proper results
Fibonacci well does it start from the
beginning Fibonacci of 0 well that looks
good let's try Fibonacci of 1 that looks
good
Fibonacci of 2 this should also be 1
that looks good
Fibonacci of 3 should this should be 2
now because we're taking the sum of 1
plus 1 that works
try the Fibonacci of 10 yeah that looks
pretty good let's try the Fibonacci of
something huge Fibonacci of 100 well
this gets a little bit I won't go into I
won't go into the the well this is a
very large number and I'm not going to
go into the whole floating kind of the
long numbers and the super large ones
but let's try something a little bit
smaller here so let's try Fibonacci of
20 so it looks like it works and you can
verify verify it for yourself so this is
just one implementation of it in the
next few videos I'm going to try another
way to implement it maybe I'll do with a
for loop what we can also do it
recursively